welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University
visit
good evening everyone my name is Thomas
wit Holton I'm a coordinator of student
development here at the University I am
here to welcome you on behalf of the
Division of Student Affairs to another
great University lecture series lecture
this evening we have you look terrible
how not to dress for a job interview
presented by Deirdre Clemente as a
former fashion writer and a current PhD
candidate in history here at Carnegie
Mellon Deirdre combines practicality
intelligence and humor into one great
speaker whose talk I hope you will
appreciate as much as I will please give
me a warm welcome to Deirdre Clemente
again a big welcome I think it's really
important that students turn out for
lecture series like that like this to
allow graduate students and faculty a
chance to talk on something that doesn't
have to do with world history or you
know whatever they happen to be studying
so thanks so much for coming as
mentioned my name is Deirdre Clemente
but today I'm going to talk about a
topic that is incredibly important to
every single person in this room and no
I'm not talking about you know the
upcoming election or even the writers
strike but I'm talking about a much more
important issue than not clothing so I
want to start off by mentioning that
finding an outfit for a job interview is
something that plagues everyone even
somebody like me who spent years working
for the fashion industry but it's
particularly difficult for college
students and today I want to help you
understand number one why college
students struggle so much with making
that transition from their casual wear
to a more formal ensemble as well as
provide you with concrete examples of
mistakes I've seen on this campus in
particular of students and the sort of
pitfalls that often befall students as
they assemble their interview wardrobe
so what's the story with college
students why is it that that I see so
many of you looking like homeless people
going to a job interview well number one
and I'm on the
incredibly guilty of this as any of you
have seen me wandering around campus in
my Princeton sweatpants the university
lifestyle is one that does not stress
appearance right you're not gonna fail
chemistry because your professor doesn't
like the outfit that you wore to class
that day especially here at Carnegie
Mellon students are incredibly focused
on their careers their career driven and
so often we spend so much attention on
making our resume look fabulous that we
neglect our appearances I don't envy the
student today because you're entering a
world of clothing and in a workplace of
clothing standards that is under radical
redefinition about 15 years ago they
came up with this idea of business
casual right this business of business
casual and so often students will look
go to a workplace for a job interview
and they'll look around and they'll see
that hey everybody has on khakis so I
can hear khakis and let me just there's
one thing I want you to take home from
this talk today is that while the
standards of the workplace have changed
the standards of what you wear to an
interview have not so you kind of have
to earn the right to look like you know
to look messy and really comfortable in
casual in other words you have to get
the job first another huge problem with
college students and dressing for a job
interview is that I mean come on guys
I taught world history here it was so
often I was handed an essay that was
very obviously written in the morning
before it was due and let me tell you
something
I always knew who went with those essays
were and when the person wrote them it's
very similar with outfits right if
you're good if you know you have a job
interview the night before come up with
what you're gonna wear put a little bit
of effort into it it will pay off so why
to close matter right I mean come on
dear just shouldn't my resume speak for
itself I put all this time into studying
for school shouldn't this you know
shouldn't this be more important than
what I wear well clothes have a variety
of necessity you serve a variety of
purposes of course we wear winter coats
when it snows right I know that the guy
who's walking
up to my front porch isn't trying to rob
me although in my neighborhood he maybe
isn't trying to grab me because he had
on a postman's outfit right so he's
delivering my nail and of course unless
you want to get hauled off to jail you
you it's you have to wear clothes or
you're gonna get arrested which I don't
recommend
and of course as many of them were
creative dressers in the audience knows
clothing expresses our own individuality
oh pardon me I forgot to put on this
sorry buddy okay alright so clothing
expresses our own individuality and I
think it's incredibly important for us
to remember that what we wear silently
broadcasts to everyone who sees us who
we are and what we're about and that's
really why what you wear to a job
interview is so incredibly important
because before you hand them your resume
before you tell them about all the
volunteer work you've done at Carnegie
Mellon they're gonna look at you and say
hey that guy has pizza sauce on his
shirt okay so as a clothing of course is
the first and most important way to make
a first impression so before I get into
the Nitty Gritty of what what so often
is going wrong I want to talk briefly a
little bit about the history of the
collegian and the casual clothes that
are associated with the college
lifestyle and this is of course my
dissertation research the title of my
dissertation is from snobs to slobs
collegiate clothing in the
transformation of the American wardrobe
and I focus on the years 1902 1960 and
according to my research collegians have
long struggled to bridge the gap between
casual and formal in fact they've been
the defining force in popularizing much
of the casual and comfortable clothes we
wear today from the beginning of the
century college students have been the
focus of media attention much like they
are today some of it good most of it bad
but this media attention scrutinizes
their behavior their morality and most
certainly their clothing time and again
college students throughout the time
period I studied and certainly today
have
criticized for their sloppy way of
dressing now each generation that I
study a study 60 years has their own
distinct sloppy way of dressing and it
changes as the years progress for
example in 1915 people were still
wearing suits to class but they were
constantly being criticised by the
mainstream media because they loved to
wear their golf outfits around campus
right these guys would go play a game of
golf and then head off and walk around
campus maybe go get a cup of coffee or
something like that and it drove the
mainstream media crazy similarly your
talk in 1930
nobody was wearing suits to class
anymore but the old classic khaki and
navy blue blazer was pretty much
standard attire for men on college
campuses and of course the media had to
have something rotten to say about this
casual way of dressing and most of all
they were criticized further for their
saddle shoes and the dirtier the saddle
shoes the more the college students
liked them now following the Second
World War
sloppy collegiates the sloppy collegiate
style was a source of constant comment
and what were the university officials
most complaining about you guessed it
jeans and the university officials put
out all of these elaborate codes and
we're talking every school from
Princeton to Penn State would put out
these elaborate codes of what you were
allowed to wear and jeans were always on
the top of the list you weren't allowed
to wear jeans outside of the dorm right
and sometimes you only glad to wear them
on in your dorm room you weren't even
allowed to go down the hall and answer
the phone in your jeans but much like
most fashion trends when you try to
regulate them they get completely out of
control so needless to say the college
students never gave up their jeans and
of course the students continued to
dress more and more casually and then
they graduated and they went into manged
into the outside world and soon other
Americans started following suit
hence the evolution of casual clothing
all started on the college campus
so why college kits well as many of you
know we live in a closed environment far
away from moms and dads and far away
from the prying eyes of the fashion
system right it's within this world that
we're able to create
a collegiate look and it sort of says
who's in and who's out and each of these
generations had their own particular
style and it's a fundamental fundamental
component of this collegiate style were
sports with sports we're sports were
something that had developed throughout
the first several decades of of the
century and sports where were was a
defining factor of how these guys
dressed I mentioned their knickers that
they love to wear around well most
people would have played a game of golf
gone into the showers you know changed
into their core clothes and gone back to
wearing their regular street clothes not
the collegiates they just continued to
wear their golf outfits and so this line
between what you wear on the basketball
court and what you wear to go hang out
with your friends at the malt shop
became incredibly blurry and that's a
one of the reasons these casual trends
took on and of course fundamentally
there were more college students than
ever before meaning that as we can see
here from this figure the number of
college students between World War one
and World War two grew fivefold we're
talking more people going to college
more people graduating and more people
taking these trends into their lives
beyond college so what's the legacy yeah
yeah you guys don't wear knickers
anymore I get that it's an unfortunate
loss to the Wardrobe but you know so
what do we have leftover from them of
course tons and tons of sportswear that
you wear today can be attributed to the
college students of the 1930s sweat
pants and have tennis shoes for example
on these were the days where you bought
your gym uniform at the beginning of the
year and you had to wear it to gym class
flip-flops oh you guys love your
flip-flops yeah I'll be on that in a
minute and flip-flops actually began
we're fundamentally popularized by as
dorm shoes of course nobody wants to
pick up a nasty toenail fungus it's
pretty bad
so you would wear these flip-flops into
the shower now flip-flops are a part of
everyday wear and one of your favorite
armor items of clothing or shorts again
popularized by the collegian in fact the
the the wearing of shorts was the major
right before jeans it happened in the
late 1920s and students and students
were insistent on wearing their shorts
they loved them they were very
comfortable they were called shorts for
short pants actually and the students of
Dartmouth were so committed in 1932
their shorts that when the university
said no more shorts at Dartmouth
they said forget an administration were
wearing them year-round and the head of
the student council and a bunch of
movers and shakers at Dartmouth insisted
on wearing their shorts and they wore
them well into February and of course
Dartmouth is in New England they lasted
until February but the legacy of their
protest lives on today so the next time
you wear your favorite shorts around
campus in the middle of the winter thank
the boys at Dartmouth so where does this
leave you right it leaves you from a
long line of sloppy dressers and perhaps
this generation of college students are
the sloppiest dressers of them all and
not to be critical and so weird this
happening what has now happened is that
college students are left trying to
navigate the choppy waters of
appropriate cash or you know appropriate
yet casual wear to wear to the office
and again I want to stress that that
when it comes to interview clothing you
always err on the side of formal so
today I'm going to just talk you briefly
through some of the seven deadly sins of
dressing for a job interview that I've
noticed on campus first of all this is
an example of you got to think before
you go right what kind of job are you
were going for if you're going to work
at a law office you're gonna wear a much
more conservative outfit then you are if
you're going to have a meeting with the
city with the editor of the city paper
write two different kinds of
environments so think about where you're
going and think about who it is that
you're going to be meeting and customize
your ensemble to that particular office
so again law firms banks much more
conservative than a place like an
architecture firm or a magazine they
give you a little bit more room for
creativity remember don't get too
creative show them you're a creative
person once you get the job
tech firms which I know so many people
in this room will be interviewing with
for internships or jobs there you know
legendarily the worst stressors of them
all my brother works for a tech firm in
Southern California and he looks like a
homeless man going to work every day but
I guess he makes a couple thousand
dollars a year so it's really not that
bad but again if you're when you're
going to the job interview really turn
it up a notch and I can't say it enough
times always err on the side of formal
syn number two people will say to me and
I'm sure there's people sitting in this
audience that say why too close mad or
deirdre I mean let's just you know I
weren't so hard I should just my resume
should speak for itself and take my
advice
as somebody who sat on the other side of
the interview desk it's very difficult
to let someone's resume speak for
themselves when their simpson's tie is
like screaming at you it's very
distracting so you know what a lot of
people don't understand is that
particular garments call to mind
particular qualities in a person and
even if the person that you're
interviewing with isn't exactly the
world's you know most fashionable person
they don't work for Vogue magazine and
they themselves look like a schlopp
right they still are going to they're
still gonna see what you have on and
instantly make associations for example
when I say to you he had on a bowtie
right what do you think of he's nerdy
he's conservative right somebody like my
dad could shoot because he does like
bowties you know so it calls to mind
instant associations that you really
want to avoid and here are some garments
that are that are the biggest offenders
in this category khakis okay
khakis started in after World War one
the soldiers wore them in World War one
they're meant to be very durable
they took them into the mainstream
wardrobe and through the 1920s they
became incredibly popular fine if you're
using an iron the problem with khakis is
the too often people bike khakis that
are made of 100% cotton right they fade
from sort of like a beige into an almost
white and when
gonna pair them with that ubiquitous
white shirt you college students love to
love to wear them with it looks like
you're walkin around like a ghost like
you're dressed in all white so the other
problem with cactus is that you wear
them too loose and you wear them without
a belt you must wear a belt with every
every single interview ensemble that you
have nothing can go about free gentlemen
so you have to keep your pakis well
pressed and that's why I recommend
getting a pair that's not made out of
100% cotton but maybe has a 15 or 20%
polyester or maybe some microfiber in it
that's gonna keep them looking nicer
longer and looking a little bit more
tailored and of course wear them up on
your hips
that's where pans are supposed to go so
give it a try it looks nice and pleats
just a word on pleats I'm not a big fan
it brings a lot of attention to your
stomach and I mean I don't know you but
I try to avoid people looking at my
stomach
anyway um of course I'm 33 not 23 so
second big garment that really irks me
and I often see problems with students
are shoes you look at this and you'll
say hey those aren't so bad I'll
probably wear those to a job interview
and I would say no you wouldn't right
look at the tread of this shoe it looks
like you should be hiking up a mountain
top or something in it that zipper all
of those eyelets this is a casual shoe
okay
similarly hiking boots 10 issues the
days of wearing high-top tennis shoes
with your outfit to the prom leave them
in the past
how about sandals on men I don't care if
it's a thousand degrees outside
do not wear sandals to a job interview
gentlemen ladies be careful with the
sandals that you choose strappy strappy
sandals they just think they're
difficult to handle and they're very
distracting if you're going to wear a
sandal because you're going to a summer
job interview keep it simple and again I
don't even know why I need to say this
because if you think you can wear a
flip-flop to a job interview you should
probably just leave the lecture now no
flip-flops I don't care if you stole
them from Kimora Lee Simmons and they
are studded with diamonds forget the
flip-flop
similarly denim
there is a terrible trend out there
people where people buy dark denim and
they try to dress it up it's dress up
denim denim was invented to dig rocks
out of riverbeds it is not made to out
weird to it that's not the impression
you want to be giving unless you're
going to like a mining company job
interview or something so and this
includes jackets and jean skirts denim
the instant association with denim is
those are my work clothes no matter how
dark the denim is leave it at home never
ever with denim similarly looking too
casual you can look too dressy dangly
earrings club shoes you look like going
out to the club okay no platforms
anything with a heads you know if you're
trying it's if you can wear it to seduce
someone don't wear it to a job interview
any kinds of shiny shirts or anything
with a little bit of sequins evening
wear save it for the evening a sparkly
eyeshadow too much makeup perfume that
makes the person gag haha nothing like
that
so again ladies you know keep it keep it
more conservative and you know these are
these are just some common offenses for
getting too dressy sin number three and
this is really the reason that I'm
giving the talk today last fall I sat
outside of the gym and during the job
fair that was on campus and I looked at
what you guys were wearing and I saw out
of 20 people I counted 20 people walking
into the giant gymnasium filled with
filled with people going to try to you
know eager faces and shiny new resumes
and out of 20 people that I counted 15
of you had on black suits right don't
get me wrong everybody needs a black
suit there are fundamental part of your
wardrobe but if you're gonna go the
black suit route you really need to have
something that Jazz's it up a little bit
because remember this person's gonna be
looking at a job fair they're going to
be looking at 60 resumes that day you're
gonna look like every other black suited
person that came through give them
something to remember you by similarly
the old khakis and sports code they're
great for prep school guys but you know
what if you're gonna go that route you
know try to try to find something
you stand out white shirt tan pants
white shirt tan pants enough set okay
quick fixes how to jazz off that black
suit this is really important and this
is really where you have a chance to you
know show a little bit of your
personality ladies I love love love a
sweater a short sleeve nice fitted
sweater with a white belt in a tailored
skirt can't go wrong with that
definitely if you want it if it's winter
and you need to wear hose and you need
to wear hose in the winter trust me
try something try some textured hose
right maybe something ribbed or
something with a little bit of a print
to it to give your outfit a little bit
of zing and I'll tell you a story about
a funky pin I used to interview all the
time when I was a fashion writer in New
York City and I used to wear this kind
of ugly now in retrospect pin on my
outfit and I always got comments on it
for people with us oh that's a nice pin
that's a night pin out say you know my
grandmother gave me that pin for my 8th
birthday because she just knew I loved
it and I just I love to wear it I always
think of her when I wear it's my good
luck pin it's my good luck pin you want
to know what I got it at the Goodwill it
wasn't from my grandma but in the end
people remembered me for the pin right I
see I stood out a little bit guys
please get beyond the white shirt in the
light blue button-down collar shirt you
know you need there's a range of colors
out there explore them sweater vest
I have a weird sort of love of sweater
vests as my husband well knows I always
try to get them to wear them and sweater
vests are a great way to look a little
bit different but still have a
conservative look to you if it's a more
sort of liberal place that you're going
to for the job interview try a sweater
vest a tie and a really nice crisp well
fitted button-down collar or how about
just a sweater with your suit and it's
in a button-down collar in it and a tie
you can work that look pocket squares if
you want to really jazz it up match your
pocket square to your tie European
classy and also if you're insistent on
wearing a sports coat
try a corduroy sports coat it gets you
out of that boring blue blazer and it
gives your outfit a little bit of
texture so guys if you're wondering what
the hell is seared you're talking about
consider Henry my fashion icon Henry of
course is ugly Betty's boyfriend but he
also happens to be the best-dressed guy
on television here we have them rockin
that sweater with the suit look we have
them in two different kinds of sweater
vests and we also have down in the
corner our old nemesis Marc who's
rocking that's that the tie with the
matching pocket square these guys look
great if you want some wardrobe
inspiration please look there ladies
don't look ugly ugly buddy for fashion
inspiration sin number four for getting
the fit and this is probably the number
one problem with college students and I
really attribute that to college
students are like vultures they like
scavenge other people's wardrobe and
when your dad says hey I have a suit you
want to wear it for your job interview
if your dad weighs 250 pounds and you
weigh a hundred and twenty the answer is
no dad no so that's one of the problems
the second problem is when you spend 360
days in sweat pants it's very difficult
to put on a pair of pants that actually
fit and not feel like you're like oh I'm
so these are so restraining so those are
the two problems of why college students
can't understand how to fit their
clothes here are some basic rules guys
jackets them you must be able to
actually button the jacket around your
stomach sleeve should come to right
after the break of your wrist right and
from there you should be able to see a
little bit of your shirt cuff sticking
out so it has collar
I mean cuff from nice jacket and a
little bit of the cuff from this from
the shirt shoulders should hang the
shoulders of your suit jacket should
hang directly on your shoulders right
and lay flat against your chest hems of
your pants should touch actually touch
the shoes it's very distracting and
terribly unattractive to have a bunch of
fabric hanging out there at the bottom
of your pants even if they're a pair of
$250 pants still I don't need that extra
fabric so
your pants hand in terms of shirts this
I call it the bobblehead phenomenon
which is when guys will have a
button-down collar shirt and it doesn't
touch the skin of their neck and it's
like I'm a bobble head
I'm evolved it's very annoying but it's
not half as annoying as what I should
launch a campus campaign against it I
call it the American fit right which is
when guys have button-down collared
shirts and they hold their arms up like
this and there's all this flabby dabby
fabric here right it's like a be like
wings or something I don't know it's I
don't understand why people make this
guy even you know produce this cut of a
shirt so what you want to do is
especially if you're a thin guy look for
a shirt that has this it's called a slim
fit Calvin Klein makes one Geoffrey
Beene makes wine Perry Ellis makes that
one and you can certainly have them
they're not expensive they're sold at
t.j.maxx you can get them for like
fifteen twenty dollars and the goal is
to have clothes that actually fits you
and flatter your body so if you're a
slim guy go for a slim fit
now while guys dress too baggy women
dress too tight right that your skirts
needed hover around the knee
none of these short little shorty short
britt nice pierre style we all know what
happened to brittany do not follow
anything she does okay so with shirts
you're gonna lay D's you want to watch
the cleavage you know you don't want to
have to get the job that way trust me
you know and the other thing is is that
you don't a big mistake women young
women make is that they wear tank tops
or something that shows their arms it's
very distracting to a job interview or
when you're showing them so much skin
right so you want to keep it a little
bit more conservative and if you do have
a big bust and you're wearing an Oxford
don't have one of these shirts that it
looks like they're you're like you're
looking they're looking to break free
right you buttons need to sit flat along
your along your chest dresses be careful
of wrap arounds I speak from experience
with the New York subways they don't
lead to disaster right nothing too
clingy and again even if it's the summer
and you want to wear like a little
sundress that you think is appropriate
for the job interview throw on a
cardigan you don't show off too much
skin fundamental rule here's some
terrible
hops the woman with the gray pants over
on the side she has all that extra
fabric I don't even need to say in the
woman in the middle what all you can say
all you can look at you just saw just
like hey there they are
the woman on the end with the black bra
and the white shirt I mean obviously
she's not going to a job interview
thankfully when in doubt get your
clothes tailored here's how much it
costs people this is not a big
investment I see you spend four dollars
on coffee at Maggie Murph before go 2
cups of coffee and get your pants to fit
this in
seasonally inappropriate clothing
anybody who knows me knows this is one
of my fundamental problems with college
since why you wear flip-flops in
December I don't know but there's two
facets of seasonally inappropriate
clothing for the wardrobe for the work
wardrobe number one is not wearing like
let's say not wearing an overcoat with
your suit and it's like snowing outside
and the second aspect is is again
certain clothes
certain fabrics and certain colors have
certain connotations of seasons with
them so for example I don't know if
anyone's ever told you this people but
velvet is a winter fabric it should only
be worn in from November until the end
of March it's a winter fabric as is wool
fur I hope you get that one any kind of
tweed which is like an ugly any kind of
nobley wool blazer for men
that's a winter blazer darker colors you
know like a big chunky pair of black
boots that you love to wear to your job
interview keep them in the winter that's
not summer as it is not a big leather
purse for example not so great past like
let's say you love yellow and you want
to wear yellow to the job interview in
the winter you'll wear a deep rich
mustard yellow in the summer you'll wear
a pastel yellow so again lighter airier
colors for it's the stuff for the summer
any kind of print that has white in it
white is the predominant color or pink
pink butterflies and you know something
like that
that's a summer print keep them to this
summer it looks really ridiculous to be
rolling up in a summer shirt into for a
winter job interview similarly linen
is also associated with with the summer
in cotton while it is a year-round
fabric again we're afraid of cotton 100%
cotton is not your friend avoid it
common pitfalls again an overcoat no
overcoat with a suit or perhaps wearing
a parka or your sports coat with your
suit it's like you guys order tennis
shoes they're two different worlds get
yourself a nice winter overcoat if you
can't get it ask your grandmother
grandmothers love to go shopping with
you right they love and they know tons
of stuff about clothes and then they'll
pay for things so keep that in mind as
well no hoes I mean ladies this is a
fundamental problem you have to wear
hoes for fall and winter job interviews
it just looks gross if you don't sandals
be careful of it again heavy or knitted
accessories for a summer job interview
now this is what I think most of your
dorm rooms must look like and you know
all the scenes that I've mentioned so
far are forgivable
maybe somebody never told you not to
wear black shoes with a navy blue suit
which of course you should never do or
athletic socks with a nice suit right
maybe somebody ever told you that but
I'm sure somebody told you that you need
to shower before you go to a job
interview and wash your hair and things
like that so remember that you're going
for a total look people and any little
thing can can take you down and again
this is where wait until the last minute
can really prove a disastrous mistake
plan ahead top 10 sloppy slip-ups
looking dirty having your hair all down
around your face pull your hair up
ladies I'm sure you have a beautiful
face pull your hair off your face it
looks very professional wrinkled clothes
stained clothes untucked or that
terrible you know guys do this they tuck
things in but then they do this blouse
out thing huh tuck it in tuck it in tuck
it in and belt it worn-out clothes again
beware of cotton no makeup little
mascara never killed anybody ladies even
the most feminists of us beat up shoes
if it's your favorite favorite favorite
favorite pair of shoes you wear every
day they're not for your job interview
okay
that means you weird them to the frat
party you don't wear them to try to get
a job rolled up sleeves and an
unbuttoned collar with a tie just say to
your interviewer yeah whatever did and
that's not the impression that you want
to be giving clothing maintenance is a
particular issue of mine never use wire
hangers never hang a suit on a wire
hanger in fact don't even hang it on one
of those plastic ones get a wooden
hanger right they're not very expensive
use a garment bag get the best-case
scenarios you put together your whole
outfit you put it in a garment bag and
you shove it into the back of your
closet and it's there when you need it
right and it's stayin out of all of the
activities that go on in the college
dorm room
similarly air out your clothes after
they come back from the dry cleaners
they use all kind of chemicals that eat
away at your fabric so here's what
you're gonna do you're gonna take that
shirt that just came back from the dry
cleaners you're gonna rip off the
plastic that they put it on you're gonna
take that wire hanger you're gonna open
up your dorm room and you're gonna fling
it out onto the quad okay get rid of the
wire hanger let the it let the shirt air
out put it on a plastic hanger and then
put the plastic covering back on it and
put it in your closet air out your
clothes it keeps them longer don't mix
your interview wardrobe with your
everyday wardrobe and this is really one
of the most fundamental points I want to
take home have you guys take home you
really have to keep them separate
because it keeps those interview clothes
looking fresh and looking a lot more
professional
shoe polish I don't know if you guys
know what that is but if you put it on
your shoe so they don't look scuffed
that was a joke and of course a sewing
kit you're an adult
get a sewing kit so at the last minute
if you do need to put a button on you
have something to do final one real
quick that that that old backpack and
remember little things speak volumes and
you can't get sentimental about your
clothes people this is coming from the
girl who has a basement full of five
suits she'll never wear again because
they're size eight but you can't get
sentimental about you know about what
you wear to your job interview and yeah
that's your favorite bag funk you've had
it since the ninth grade
let me tell you something it looks like
you've had it since the ninth grade you
really want to make sure that you're
wearing things that look fresh and speak
to the up-and-comer that you are
alternatives to the hideous college
backpack look at them all they're
beautiful I mean come on people
messenger bags don't put any protest
pins or any kind of writing on it make
sure you keep them fresh you know it's
it just gives them more polished look
other offenders any kind of necklace
that you wear all the time and maybe
it's like a from senior week five years
ago don't but to take it off don't wear
it to the interview your favorite pair
of shoes again some sort of funky weird
accessory that everybody on campus knows
you for yeah let that one go Bart
Simpson watches Mickey Mouse watches
like how are they gonna take you
professional you know as a professional
person if you're wearing a Mickey Mouse
watch too many rings too many earrings
these are very distracting to job
interviewers so take them out and of
course a word on tattoos and piercings I
know this is something a lot of people
have you know and generally you're going
to interview with somebody from a
different generation they don't
understand the trend so hey keep it
under wraps until you get the job
so take-home points number one you're
part of a long line of sloppy dressers
so embrace it while you're still in
college and feel free to wear your
sweatpants every single day that you're
not going to a job interview and despite
the role of more casual dress in the
workplace remember you still have to
dress formally for your job interviews
it really is incredibly important in
making the kind of impression that you
want to make looking good means being
prepared spend the time the night before
to figure out what you're gonna wear
iron it up things like that maintain a
separate wardrobe for your interviewer
for your interview wear and make sure
that it fits put the extra effort in if
you need help ask someone you have my
email address I know I'll probably
regret saying that but you know if it's
not me it's your mom your sister or your
brother who's really into clothes
somebody who can help you make sure it
fits don't be afraid to add into a dash
of personality but don't try to wow them
over with your unique outfit right you
can show them how you
eqr once you have that job and finally
if there's one thing I want you guys to
remember please buy an iron so that
wraps up my presentation I have some I
have some very brave volunteers that I'm
gonna call up to the stage and ask them
to you know together we can give a
little bit of critique and then I'll
take a couple questions we'll wrap it up
here in about ten minutes so first I'm
going to call up Anna come on up Anna I
mean give her a round of applause she
has some guts she has some guts all
right here we go
she's as cute as Christmas sure you can
see all right here we have what's what's
our main issue with Anna black suit okay
but the cool thing about Anna suit is it
have a little bit of texture to it I
don't know if you can see it there but
it has a little bit of texture to the
fabric so it looks really nice um any
other thoughts on Anna I'll tell you
what one of my thoughts would be anybody
out there her hair you know she's
beautiful pull that hair off your face
pull up here to pull it up in a bun and
give yourself that really polished
professional look anything else what are
we thinking about how about that shirt
it's cotton it's cotton it looks like
maybe she wore it to to go to class
earlier today and she put just put on
the suit to dress it up a little bit and
again I love to see in her shoes look
huge she has on hose yes you know I'd
love to see you know with her hair
pulled back and maybe you know some Kurt
that was a little bit more crisp a
little bit more you know fresh looking
and of course maybe you know maybe a
nice pair of small earrings or a
necklace or even a pin or something like
that to give her a little just give her
a little bit of zing but I think she'll
I think she looks pretty darn good and I
like the suit actually all right thanks
thanks honey
alright next who else do I have in the
audience Doherty bring it on up come on
now Jimmy what Chris be going to some
kind of a job interview at a law firm or
someplace so he's going to be calling
for a much more conservative
conservative look and and you know again
we have to consider where we're going to
get the job before we decide what we're
gonna wear James here we go
all right okay Jimmy I don't know if you
can see it he has on a striped suit and
a striped tie how do we feel about that
stripy I'm striped okay so that would be
my first criticism of Jimmy what else
what does he have going wrong people too
much cologne my husband shouts from the
back okay next you just for me I love it
he did that one just to get on my nerves
I'm sure a lot of these things he picked
just to drive me crazy
white socks I mean oh I would I would
fire him before I even hired him okay
how about what else does he have we have
we see the big offender oh the backpack
the legendary backpack which I'm sure he
brought purposely to annoy me because he
knows my he knows my standards and he
usually adheres to them but again
beautiful suit really nice fit I'll make
sure I pulled my cuffs down so you could
see them at the end of the at the end of
the suit I'll avoid wearing stripes too
with stripes
especially when the stripes are is
prominent on the suit as his are and as
prominent on the tie as his are and you
know looks pretty good it looks like he
has something in his pocket there I
don't know if it's like a cell phone or
something but again that cuts the line
of the pants a little bit so be careful
of that okay Jimmy
not too shabby not too shabby anybody
else before I take questions yeah bring
it on down this is John he looks pretty
good I have to say okay let's see what
he has going on here
nice suit a hideous tie nice do what do
we have to say what do we have to say to
John I like the suit and it's a very
nice fit it is black but you know of
course he does have a colorful time you
can say that about sometimes it's
colorful right what else do we have
going people shave Goodwin jazz it up a
little bit with a shade unless you're
trying to work that like member of the
lost cast look going on which I mean
I've seen some of those members not too
bad even look in casual shoes I would
say I would say his shoes are slip ons
and they look very much like they could
go with a much more casual outfit than a
suit so I would certainly try a more
formal shoe and let me see you have a
belt on yay okay that's pretty good so
again maybe a less mr. Huxtable tie you
know this isn't the Cosby Show
so a nicer pair of shoes and a good
shave but I'll say that suit is a
definite keeper good work and thanks for
coming